prime minister two weeks ago you said
the intelligence was particularly gloomy
when asked about the inevitability of a
russian invasion into ukraine since then
the combination of the threat of
sanctions deploying
troops to eastern allies diplomacy has
failed to de-escalate
this situation
are you coming to the conclusion that
president putin actually wants this war
and to secretary general you just said
that this was a dangerous moment for
european security different allies from
france to the uk
to the us are taking slightly different
approaches to dealing with russia
are you concerned about these different
approaches sending mixed messages to
russia and are you worried that
differences between partners could
hinder any nato deployment thank you
thanks thanks very much beth look i i
think that this is
um
to answer your question directly about
what i think is going on in moscow and
the calculations that are being made
there i
i don't i honestly don't think a
decision has yet been taken but that
doesn't mean
that it is
uh
impossible that something absolutely
disastrous could happen very soon indeed
and our intelligence i'm afraid to
to say remains
grim and we're seeing the massing of uh
of huge numbers of uh of tactical
battalion groups uh potential groups on
the on the borders of of ukraine uh 70
or more this is probably the most
dangerous moment
uh i would say in the in the course of
the next few days in what is the uh
biggest security crisis that
europe has faced for decades and
we've got to get it right and i think
that the combination of
uh sanctions and
uh
military resolve
plus diplomacy
is are what is in order and
everybody understands the
you you ask about whether uh where where
it won across the west on sanctions i
think increasingly actually we are at
one
and i think that i i congratulate uh
olaf schultz uh of germany on the way
he's been able to move towards a tougher
position on on nordstrom too difficult
though obviously that is
for germany and for for the german
economy uh i think that the uk has been
able to help to bring people together
with a with an automatic package of
sanctions that would hit uh
russian commercial uh strategic
strategic commercial interests uh the
tougher
those sanctions are the more automatic
they are the more chance we have of of
deterring what i think would be an
irrational response but what we're also
doing
is uh ensuring that we have a uh
we engage uh
the russians attention we occupy their
bandwidth uh and uh we get ready all
over the eastern frontier of nato and
that's why jens was kind enough to
mention all the things that uh that
we're doing where we're supporting
operation uh cold response in uh up in
the north in the in the in the norway
area with uh the prince of hms prince of
wales uh 16 air assault brigade uh in
estonia we're doubling the uh the
presence of tapa the enhanced forward
presence of tapa
in poland we're adding uh where i'll be
going shortly we're adding another 300
350 uh troops from uh four five commando
we're doing air policing in romania uh
increasing the number of typhoons that
we're deploying out of uh out of cyprus
uh by a a squadron of typhoons and we're
sending ships to the eastern
mediterranean and the and the black sea
and opv and uh uh at a type uh 45 and
that's uh as i think uh
as against referred to were also uh
putting on stand by a thousand troops uh
in preparation for a a humanitarian
crisis that may take place on nato's uh
eastern uh frontiers so
we're getting ready uh a military
we're making military preparations we're
getting ready economic sanctions
but we're also
willing to to talk and i think i think
yen summed it up uh very well in in what
he said uh you know there are some
things that are
non-negotiable
uh that's the idea of a europe whole and
free that's the idea that uh nato must
have an open door policy that the people
of ukraine must be able to aspire
to nato membership and then of course
there are things that it would be
sensible to talk about and things that
uh nato and the uk the us everybody is
willing certainly to to discuss and they
include
transparency about nato exercises
about nato force posture uh about the
the stationing of of missiles uh making
progress on certainly as as yen said on
the uh the
inf uh
uh area where where russia is is in
breach and making progress on
intermediate nuclear uh missiles
all those
are subjects for discussion and far far
better to begin a discussion now uh than
to
uh
have a catastrophe so that's what that's
what we're pushing for and uh there's a
lot of
of effort going in on all those fronts
but beth you know whether it's going to
pay off now whether we're going to be
successful
i simply can't say
then on the unity of the alliance i
think what we have seen over the last
weeks and months is actually a very
united nato where we stand together both
when it comes to
our diplomatic efforts but also when it
comes to the necessary military
adaptation we have uh implemented
on the diplomatic efforts all allies
agree that we need to
sit down with rashaan to engage in good
faith in talks to try to find a
political peaceful solution to the
conflict and that's the reason why
we have invited russia for meetings in
the format of the nato-russia council
why i welcome that
nato allies as the united kingdom but
also other allies engaged directly with
russia secretary stresses in moscow
today
and other allies have reached out
because we need
a broad approach when it comes to
our diplomatic efforts um with uh with
russia but this is based on a unified
message which all nato allies has agreed
we agreed
a comprehensive document which was sent
over to russia as uh as our common
response of you as our united response
to the
legally binding uh treaties that russia
proposed for us uh some weeks ago
and this is the agreed basis this is a
great message exactly as boris said
we list areas we're ready to sit and
discuss
on arms control missiles nuclear many
other issues
the point is it has to be verifiable and
balanced uh and then we list also uh
some areas where we cannot make
compromises especially the right for
every nation to choose his own path and
the right of course for nato to defend
and protect uh all uh allies this idea
that that we should introduce some kind
of second-class allies those allies that
have joined nato after 1997 uh is
absolutely not acceptable for us
but but verifiable balanced arms control
that's something we absolutely are in
favor of and ready to engage in with uh
with uh with russia
um
let me just briefly also add that
the military
adaptation
uh
sends a clear signal that that that
russia has a choice they can either
choose a diplomatic solution and we are
ready to sit down but if they choose
confrontation they will pay a high price
there will be economic sanctions there
will be
increased
nato military presence in eastern part
of the alliance uk is really
par an important part of that already
announced
new deployments uh on top of what uh uk
has already um
deployed in eastern part alliance
and of course the ukrainian army defence
force is much stronger now
than they were in 2014
because uh
they're better equipped better trained a
better command and uh uh and and i
welcome that united kingdom and other
allies uh provide support to the
ukrainian uh defence forces so they can
defend themselves this is a
right for every nation to defend
themselves for self-defense and uh and
it's good that nato allies like the
united kingdom uh help ukraine to
to uphold that uh right
you